foreign
it's no secret that the god of the Bible
has a darker side throughout the Old
Testament God is responsible for a whole
slew of natural disasters from a racing
life on Earth in a world-ending flood to
unleashing devastating plagues of
biblical proportions like it or not God
has a death toll question is has anyone
gone through the Bible and counted it
armed with a calculator a spreadsheet
and a King James version I have done
just that I want to figure out how many
people in the Bible can missed God as a
cause of death turns out there is a
precise number and it's in the millions
it's a horrifying statistic especially
compared with Satan who has a measly 10
but what does this mean what's the
explanation behind this figure all this
and more as we unravel God's biblical
kill count
our search begins in the Old Testament
the section of the Bible that covers the
history of Israel Within These Pages
you're never too far away from a
Biblical disaster like when God engulfed
an entire city in Flames this violent
depiction of God has always fascinated
me it's so different to the peaceful god
of the New Testament I want to find an
explanation for this Behavior one that's
rooted in the history of this book but
to know what we're dealing with we need
some numbers how many people does God
actually kill in the Bible so I opened
up a copy and began counting it felt
like going through a celebrity's Twitter
feed and finding some unsavory things
from the past but instead of old tweets
it was the Old Testament here are some
examples of what I found and fire came
out from the Lord and consumed 250 men
then the Lord sent poisonous serpent
among the people and they bit the people
so that many Israelites died at midnight
the Lord struck down all the firstborn
in the land of Egypt I collected them
into a single spreadsheet this vast
document records God's biblical death
count each entry has a brief description
and a corresponding biblical verse I'm
not the first to attempt this by the way
I've relied at times on the work of
Steve Wells an author whose book and
website contain a meticulously thorough
list
in the Bible deaths caused by God fall
into two categories one with exact
numbers and one without numbers at all
I'll start my search in the parts where
the Bible gives precise figures some of
these biblical outbursts incur a very
high death toll indeed like when 50 070
men are pulverized for glimpsing inside
the Ark of the Covenant but that's
nothing compared to the time when God
sends an angel to wipe out 185
000 soldiers in one night it's nice to
see a Bible accurate angel in this
natural habitat other incidents are
plain strange in one story a group of
boys teased the prophet Elisha for being
bald they say and I'm directly quoting
here go away bald head go away bald head
upset by these hurtful comments the
prophet calls upon God to teach the boys
some manners suddenly a pack of bears
appear to eat 42 of them I'm still not
sure what the moral to this tale is
don't tease bald people the numbers keep
adding up and the total gets larger and
larger if you add up all deaths that the
Bible attributes to God you arrive at
two million five hundred and fifty nine
thousand four hundred and forty nine two
and a half million compare that with the
ten deaths attributed to Satan an
overwhelming majority comes from the Old
Testament there are only four
god-related deaths from the New
Testament it's a big statistic for sure
but we're not even close to the real
figure so far we've only counted deaths
where the Bible gives an exact number we
haven't added up the parts where no
number is given for example how many
people is a city or an army a thousand
ten thousand the best we can do is use
historical estimates and rely on
educated guesswork adding them all up
the number now jumps to four million 681
116.
ouch but there's one more event we
haven't yet factored in the great flood
in the Book of Genesis the cataclysmic
event where God decides to drown
everything under water sparing Noah and
his Arc full of animals using the
internal dating of the Bible the year of
the flood would have been 2
348 BC all we need to do now is figure
out what Earth's human population would
have been historical estimates range
from 14 million to 27 million I'm going
to settle somewhere in the middle and
say 20 million adding this to the count
we arrive at the final number ready for
it God's biblical kill count including
the flood and other estimate is 24
681
116. this is an eye-watering number to
put that into context that's
approximately 34 hotalagas maybe
subscriber count is not a helpful metric
Gods Define death toll is a statistic
that some would rather not know but
again it's using data gathered from the
Bible itself even if we remove the flood
and the various estimations adding up
the exact numbers the Bible gives us is
still in the millions so why is God's
biblical kill count so high and what
does this say about God this is a really
difficult conundrum in the field of
biblical studies it's also an
uncomfortable truth that's kept
religious thinkers occupied in fact this
debate goes back to the dawn of
Christianity itself in 144 A.D a
Christian thinker called marcian had an
idea what if there are two Gods a
vengeful god of the Old Testament and a
loving God of the New Testament
marcianism as it came to be known was a
popular theory in its day having two
Gods explained why there's such a
discrepancy between the two opposite
depictions of him but marcian and his
two Gods theory was swiftly denounced as
one of the very first Christian heresies
his critics accused him of cherry
picking you can't just remove the bits
you don't like plus isn't there supposed
to be one God
like it or not the Old Testament God is
here to stay so how else have people
attempted to explain his death toll
there are plenty of religious and
Theological explanations for God's
biblical kill count but I think the one
rooted in history is the most satisfying
to understand God in the Old Testament
you have to understand the world the Old
Testament came from to the ancient
Hebrews living in 500 BC God was
depicted as a great king ruling creation
from his Celestial throne in the sky now
an ancient King does two things the
first is to uphold the law the Old
Testament is full of sacred rules there
are 613 of them like don't worship false
idols and keep the Sabbath day holy a
lot of deaths in the Old Testament are
because people break God's rules
worshiping a golden calf zap collecting
wood on the Sabbath day zap opening the
Ark of the cup Covenant Mega zap in
every instance people are told not to
but they do it anyway the death penalty
may seem harsh but those are the rules
disobey a Divine Law and expect a Divine
punishment an eye for an eye as the
biblical saying goes a saying
incidentally that's been borrowed from
King Hammurabi's Code a collection of
Babylonian laws that predate the Bible
considerably like any good Mesopotamian
King the god of the Old Testament was a
Divine rule maker judge jury and
executioner too
but maintaining Law and Order is only
half of a king's duties what else does
an ancient ruler do he goes to war a
large proportion of God's biblical
deaths are connected to Warfare whether
that be granting Israelites victory in
battle or using super-powered angels to
demolish enemy armies similar to the
deities of neighboring societies the
biblical God was viewed as the protector
of a nation and so was often described
as a warrior in fact one of the oldest
bits in the Bible the song of Moses is a
poem praising God's military might the
Lord is a warrior the Lord is his name
Pharaoh's Chariot and his army he cast
into the ocean his chosen officers were
sunk in the Red Sea it's the closest
thing you get to biblical Heavy Metal
the writers behind the Old Testament
wanted to describe God as a powerful
king a king who upholds the law and
ensures success on the battlefield it's
a gruesome Affair but hey who said Being
a king was easy compared with other
ancient deities the biblical God is a
pretty nice guy take the flood story at
least God is described as regretting his
decision in another version of this
ancient myth the Epic of atrohasis the
reason why the gods drown humankind is
for
partying too loud
centuries later when the New Testament
writings came along Christian writers no
longer used words like judge and Warrior
to describe their God instead they used
words like father now fathers don't
execute their subordinates they forgive
them which is why forgiveness and grace
are such big themes in Christianity
that's why God's biblical kill count
feels so jarring this gigantic statistic
is a hang up from the Old Testament
these ancient Hebrew writers pictured
God in a very different way than we do
today to them death was simply part and
parcel of being a god combing through
the Bible and calculating God's death
toll culminates with a frightening
number it can be quite hard to make
sense of I'm not religious myself so I
find Historical explanations like these
the most helpful it's one of those head
scratching questions that have kept
people busy and probably will do for San
centuries to come
hey thanks for watching I had a great
time making this and I hope you enjoyed
it too if you like this video and want
to see more why not subscribe a like and
a comment also go a really long way oh
and do check out the Channel's merch
over at crowdmate we have beanies
t-shirts and hoodies links are in the
description down below anyway I look
forward to seeing you next time
goodbye